JEFF FLAKE, CORY BOOKER, ALL TOO
SCARED ON TO COME ON THING EXTRA
BUSY.
NOT ROB REINER.
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
THIS WAS ALL HAPPENING JUST SO
YOU GET THIS, DEMOCRATS ARE
HOLDING UP A SPENDING BILL,
HOLDING IT HOSTAGE, FOR THEIR
DEMANDS, FOR AMNESTY FOR
DREAMERS.
CONNECTING TWO.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE CONNECTED.
TO GET INSIDE THE STORY, LET
GOES TO SENATOR JAMES LANG DLPT
FORD, A REPUBLICAN FROM
OKLAHOMA, WHO BUSINESS TO GO ON
THAT FLOOR AND VOTE.
SENATOR LANGFORD, GREAT TO SEE
YOU, ON THE RADIO THIS MORNING,
ON WITH ME NOW, APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME.
TELL US WHERE THINGS STAND AFTER
THAT MEETING THAT THE PRESIDENT
WAS IN THE ROOM WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND SCHUMER.
NO OTHER STAFFER, OF SCHUMER, I
LOUED IN OR HE DIDN'T BRING
THEM.
>> I'M NOMENT SURE.
I WASN'T INVIEPTED INTO THAT
MEETING EITHER.
LIST OF DEMANDS THAT HE WANTED
TO BE ABLE TO SEE BE ADDRESSED.
THE PRESIDENT TOLD HIM, HEY,
THIS IS A LEGISLATIVE BRANCH
ISSUE, WORK IT OUT WITH THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AND
MAJORITY LEADER OF THE SENATE,
Y'ALL WORK IT OUT, I WON'T
INTERVENE.
HE BASICALLY TURNED SENATOR
SCHUMER BACK AROUND, SENT HIM
BACK TO CAPITOL HILL, SAID Y'ALL
WORK IT OUT.
>> Laura: WAIT SECOND HOOECHLT
SHOWS UP WITH A LIST OF DE
HANDS, THIS IS AFTER THAT
DISASTER VISIT THAT SENATOR
GRAHAM AND SENATOR DURBIN HAD TO
THE OVAL, WHERE THEY GO AND
PUTS MORE PRESSURE, SENATOR
PRESIDENT REQUESTED FOR THE
BORDER.
THE TWO THINGS THE PRESIDENT
CARED ABOUT, THEY ACTUALLY
EXACERBATE.
ON THE DIVERSE YIPT LOTTERY
ISSUE, THEY -- DIVERSITY LOTTERY
THEY TAKE AND TRANSFER HALF OF
THEM TO THE OTHER PROTECTED
STATUS CATEGORY.
ON PRETTY MUCH EVERY FRONT THEY
DID NOT REALLY MOVE TO THE
PRESIDENT'S POSITION.
NOW THEY'RE ACTUALLY ASKING FOR
MORE DEMANDS?
>> APPARENTLY SO.
AND, AGAIN, YOU LEFT OUT ONE
SIMPLE THING, AS WELL ON
TUESDAY, THEY LAID OUT A PROCESS
FOR HOW WE WERE GOING TO COME TO
CONCLUSION ON THIS.
ON THURSDAY OF THAT WEEK THEY
CAME IN AND SAID WE WANT TO GO
AROUND THE PROCESS WE AGREED TO
ON TUESDAY.
AGAIN, THE PRESIDENT WAS HAVING
HILL.
WHERE IT HAS TO BE NEGOTIATED
AND HAS TO BE RESOLVED.
AT THE END OF THE DAY ALL OF
THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT DACA
THAT'S THE THING THAT'S MISSING.
WE DON'T HAVE A DACA PROBLEM, WE
DON'T HAVE AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION PROBLEM IF WE HAVE
GOOD BORDER SECURITY.
>> Laura: EXACTLY.
WE LITIGATED THIS ISSUE IN THE
2016 ELECTION CYCLE.
DECEMBER OF 2015 HE WAS SO
POPULAR, KNEW HE COULDN'T EVEN
WIN HIS OWN STATE.
DONALD TRUMP WINS.
YET WE'RE STILL, WE STILL HAVE
REPUBLICANS LIKE LINDSAY GRAHAM,
GOD BLESS HIM, BANDING TOGETHER
WITH DICK DURBIN AND JEFF FLAKE
WHO DIDN'T VOTE FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP TO PUSH THIS ISSUE AGAIN.
IT'S LIKE, THIS IS CRAZYTOWN
STUFF.
THE PRESIDENT WILL NOT GO ALONG
WITH THIS.
AND YET LINDSAY GRAHAM, I WANT
TO PLAY THIS, IS OUT THERE
AND STEVEN MILLER AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> THE STEVEN MILLER APPROACH TO
IMMIGRATION HAS NO VIABILITY.
TUESDAY THE PRESIDENT WAS IN A
GOOD PLACE.
HE WAS THE PRESIDENT OF ALL OF
US, HE SPOKE COMPASSIONATELY
ABOUT IMMIGRATION, TOUGH ON
SECURITY, BIPARTISANSHIP.
TWO DAYS LATER A MAJOR CHANGE.
I THINK THE CHANGE COMES ABOUT
FROM PEOPLE LIKE MR. MILLER, TOM
COTTON APPROACH HAS NO VIABILITY
HERE.
HE'S BECOME SORT SPEECH KING OF
THE SENATE.
>> Laura: COTTON RESPONDED WITH
I THINK CAN I WIN MY HOME STATE,
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A REALLY CHEAP
SHOT BY SENATOR GRAHAM, AGAIN,
HIM WIN.
MEETING ON TUESDAY AND I DON'T
KNOW, I WASN'T IN THE MEETING ON
HE WAS VERY CLEAR ON IT LAST
OCTOBER.
IT'S BEEN INTERESTING TO HEAR
THE NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS IN THE
LAST 24 THUNDERSHOWERS THAT SAY
THE PRESIDENT WON'T TELL US WHAT
HE WANTS ON IMMIGRATION.
HE'S LOOKING FOR ON IMMIGRATION.
THAT WAS FOUR MONTHS AGO.
THEY CAN'T SAY HE DIDN'T GIVE
THEM ANYTHING, THEY JUST DIDN'T
LIKE IT.
WE GOT IT AND GOT IT LAID OUT
GIVE LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE IN THE
NEXT 72 HOURS, THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
HE'S BEEN CLEAR ON THE GOODLATTE
BILL.
>> Laura: WE HAD LABRADOR AND
GOODLATTE BILL.
THEN MITCH McCONNELL SAYS WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PRESIDENT
STANDS FOR.
IT CONFUSES ME.
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T GET OFF THE
HOOK ON A SHUTDOWN, CNN POLL
JUST CAME OF THE, WHICH DO YOU
THINK IS MORE IMPORTANT FOR
CONGRESS TO DO, AVOID A
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN, 56%
WHO DO YOU THINK IS RESPONSIBLE
CONGRESS 28%.
REPUBLICANS IN ONE POLL DON'T
FARE ALL THAT WELL ON WHO'S TO
BLAME FOR THE SHUTDOWN.
YET, BOY, IT SEEMS LIKE THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
>> IT'S REMARKABLE.
WE SHOULD NOT HAVE A SHUTDOWN
OVER SOMETHING THAT HAS A
DEADLINE ON AN IMMIGRATION
CONVERSATION OF MARCH 5.
IN THE MIDDLE OF JANUARY.
POINT BY ANY MEANS.
OTHER THING THAT'S INTERESTING
TO ME, WHEN REPUBLICANS WERE IN
THE MINORITY THEY WERE BLAMED
FOR THE SHUTDOWN.
WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE IN THE
NO WAY DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO
REAGAN ADMINISTRATION THREE
TIMES ON PRESIDENT REAGAN,
REAGAN WAS BLAMED FOR THE
SHUTDOWN EVERY TIME.
WE GET THE NARRATIVE, WE
NO ONE WANTS A SHUTDOWN,
DESTABILIZES EVERY FEDERAL
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SHUSN'T SAVE MONEY.
WE CONSTANTLY GET THE BLAME.
>> Laura: AND I HAVE TO TELL
YOU, SENATOR LANGFORD, NOT EVEN
AS FUN AS 2013, BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY DOCTOR SUES READINGS
SCHEDULED AS FAR AS CAN I TELL.
CHILDREN AROUND THE COUNTRY BUT